what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
is so in truth I absolutely love the
character of War Shack in my mind he's
probably like the standout star of
Watchmen and I feel like I'm not the
only one who feels that way I feel like
a lot of people really look at the
character of Rorschach and absolutely
love him I'm not going to get into a
whole debate of war Shaq vs. Batman I'm
actually leave that to you guys who do
you think would win in a fight Rorschach
or Batman like an impromptu fight no
prep time who do you think will come out
on top
I imagine the the arguments are going to
be kind of insane but but I'm just kind
of curious honestly the one thing I'm
looking forward to the most it's like a
Rorschach Batman team-up that would be
amazing that would be so cool to see
where Shaq and Batman in the same comic
together I would go absolutely nuts but
war Shaq is is dark I mean it's crazy
and his comic reflects that of course
you know before the Washington gives us
the event of these characters before
Watchmen happens now in truth with
Rorschach we don't really get like a
tried and true origin per se so because
of the fact that we got that and
Watchmen number 6 when we learned that
he was basically the son of a of a woman
who is a prostitute he doesn't know his
father's name his mother was constantly
abusive towards him and it wasn't it's
really gotten to fight with some bullies
that he was actually removed from the
house because of living conditions were
so bad but were Shaq's role within the
realm of the washroom there's really
just kind of picking up where he
believed the police had failed in the
sense that there were some criminals out
there who didn't deserve prison there
are some criminals out there who didn't
deserve the ability to repent for their
crimes
just because the fact that their crimes
were so heinous and that's one of the
crazy things about this is because were
shocked in a lot of ways is a more
extreme version of Batman we know that
that man's general rule despite how
reactions by how he conducts himself is
this whole notion of everyone deserves
the ability to be rehabilitated that's
why do we kill the Joker his argument is
that if he if we can keep the Joker in
Arkham Asylum
given enough time the Joker can be
rehabilitated or at the very least the
Joker is so far gone that he suddenly
just needs to be kept away from
everybody else but with war shack it's a
lot more visceral it's a lot more real
because in his mind the scum of
existence are people who continue to
repeat crimes they're they commit a
crime they're thrown in jail they're led
out and they commit crimes again in the
eyes of war shock there are no second
chances if you commit a crime that's it
now there are certain things you just
doesn't really care about I mean in
truth like a purse snatcher isn't really
something he'd pay special attention to
and this story he's actually kind of
interested or at least he's pursuing a
guy called the Bard but really more
so than that or at least was a crime
going on with a guy called the BART more
so than that what he's looking for is a
is really like a major hustler a guy who
is really peddling drugs within the city
and again one of the ways this starts
with is just some random guy really guy
named by the name of Dwayne Carter who's
just like a street hustler I mean that's
really it but this shows us the brutal
nature of war shock right I mean to get
information out of this guy he just
starts beating the crap out of them he
breaks some fingers you know he
basically threatens to break his arm and
he does all kinds of things to basically
turn this guy's life upside down the
other half of this is that were shaq has
developed a reputation as dark as
sadistic as twisted as it is this
reputation that he's not a man to be
messed with that he's not a man to be
trifled with now again you know were
sharks really just kind of going for
this hole taking down these various drug
drug peddlers taking down these larger
criminals different things like that and
of course this is one of those scenarios
was really more of deal with the cause
of the problem instead of the symptom
you treat the Cowles you don't street
you don't treat the symptoms and so
because of that ignoring prostitutes
ignoring all that kind of different
stuff he focuses on what he considers to
be the big fish a guy by the name of raw
head and that's kind of what's ironic
here is because there's a murder a
series of murders taking place with a
guy named the bard and war shack doesn't
be with any of that he's got bigger fish
to fry he's got major things to focus on
now what this is designed to do is show
us the Rorschach picks and chooses what
it is he goes after but more so than
that there are things again the simply
just are not worth this time or that he
intends to kind of follow up with later
on so it's really sort of interesting
when it comes to the BART of course what
we end up finding out is that he had
basically just gone through and just you
know killed various women it seemed like
women of the night or at least women
that he just explicitly targeted and
encouraged their bodies and then just
kind of leaves them in a dumpster
somewhere but the fact remains that
after war shock comes into contact with
raw heads and raw head to guys you know
beat the crap out of war shock the
initial idea is to take off the mask and
see who's underneath but for raw head
what he says is that in his mind work
shock was like this bigger than life
kind of guy right we're fiat amassed
this massive reputation you know
criminals around the city once fleeing
and you know shaking in their boots
we're not when war shot comes calling
when in the mind of raw head he looks
and it says like you're a lot smaller
than I thought you would be you really
can't be that tough have you've been
taken out this easily and so with war
shock more or less down and effectively
just kind of left for dead
raw headedness guys sort of take to the
city now that's what
interesting about this is that in a lot
of ways Rorschach is very street-level
you know he's very on the ground floor
he's not taking out you know these major
international drug criminals or anything
like that it's the smaller guys it's the
local guys who think that they're big
fish who think that they're a big deal
now again the reputation is more than
just were Shaq fighting out bad guys
it's making bad guys afraid of him it's
very much what Batman does in terms of
his whole fear aspects you know you read
any Batman comics somewhere along the
line he's basically going to say the
fear is just as much of a weapon for him
as the various gadgets and his mind and
so with war Shaq it's much the same way
but the other half of this war Shaq
makes his escape at this point he
actually is up kind of stumbling into a
diner with a particular woman now we
don't know her name right off the bat
all we know is that Rorschach has been
coming there routinely and then getting
breakfast there almost every single time
but at the same time there's discussions
on how the world is now again from war
shacks perspective everything is really
dark the world is really twisted we know
this is really just a byproduct of his
upbringing the bad experiences that he's
had the explanation he offers in terms
of why he looks that way is because he
was quote-unquote mugged you know it's
really just kind of operate he's these
half explanations these half truths now
the reason why work Shaq does is
remember no one really knows what
Rorschach looks like without the mask
the secret identity he has is one of his
most useful weapons because he can
literally cried in plain sight he can
just kind of stand around and watch
things unfold and no one's any of the
wiser he could walk right by raw head
and raw head would have no idea who it
was
that he was walking past he'd have no
idea that it was Rorschach now of course
this also leads to a to work shot going
through and pursuing a handful of these
criminals and things like that some
various members of raw heads team in
open daylight and this is kind of a big
deal because this shows us the lengths
that Rorschach will go to whether it's
light whether it's dark somebody's not
making it out of this you know not
making you out of the situation somebody
here is almost done with all their
living and war Shaq will ensure that
happens so that's kind of what's cool
about this it's because he will go to
the ends of the earth to make sure that
justice is done now of course with one
of these guys injured by a vehicle is
driving via the whole identity the
ability for people to not know what he
looks like comes into play now this is a
bit of irony that's being given here
yeah in the sense that DC is really just
kind of sitting down at least this was
written by DC at the time but it's one
just kind of sitting down and saying hey
look you know had they known what he'd
looked like things would have been a
whole lot easier and in fact we'll see
here in a little while but were shocked
actually torches one of the guys
basically throws a Molotov cocktail and
burns him alive now of course with the
one survivor basically going to wrong
head with a message in the form of a
piece of paper for the Rorschach inkblot
test on it the message here is that war
track is still very much alive and war
Shack is going to be coming for all of
them now of course passing out in the in
the local diner
you know after arriving you know
speaking with this woman for a little
bit and then waking up in the hospital
this is kind of cool because again it
shows us how durable and how resilient
war shock is and the various people that
he goes against and the various people
that he faces off with of course we also
end up picking up with a woman who's
basically dealing with her pimp more or
less and the guys being the absolute
hell out of her but the reason why is
because he works for raw head and in his
mind you know he has to pay the raw head
you know he's making the argument that
she's really not bringing in enough
money or whatever the case may be but
with war shock taking this guy out the
woman is allowed to go back to her life
now this is really kind of interesting
this is a little bit ironic because what
this does is it paints this picture that
this woman has an opportunity to
basically walk away from the life that
she's been in but she goes right back to
that life now the reason why she pursues
it is something that's just not given to
us and we could speculate on her
backstory and really make up anything we
wanted to but we're not going to I was
simply going to say is this is an
indication in this story where people
choose in a lot of ways the paths that
they're on and that's really the basis
behind worship right he could walk away
from this life anytime he wanted to he
could just walk away he could just stop
everything that he's doing but it's
almost like a compulsion it's almost
like something he has to do it's almost
like he can't walk away from his life
because this is the only thing he has
this is the purpose that he serves if
this life isn't here then what else does
he have now in terms of the ruthlessness
of worship this is probably one of the
most ruthless things I've ever seen him
do he puts a piece of glass in the guy's
mouth and then punches it shattering the
glass and destroying the side of the
guys the guys cheek that is cold-blooded
I mean that is ruthless about as
ruthless as it can get now of course
this guy doesn't necessarily dump all
the information that were shacks looking
for which of course leads him you know
back into the fray and facing off
against a handful of these other goons
who have come to this guy's rescue but
of course again jumping out the window
making his escape we end up having him
talk to just a random guy now the funny
thing about this conversation that he
has with this way and a cab driver is
that it's just as much about perception
as it is about reality
right I mean Rorschach says the
City day listen you know New York all
that kind of stuff that it's all just
it's garbage is trash the city is
effectively dying because the people in
it are amoral the people in it have no
real moral compass they just satisfy
their own base desires and that's it
whether it's businessmen hookers drug
users and so on down at the bottom and
everybody in between people just live on
their own base animalistic instincts and
in his mind this city is basically
falling apart of the seams and it's
inherently dying
what does conversation with the
cabdriver shows us is that it's not
necessarily that way it's war shacks
perception but how he views the world
clay views a city is not necessarily how
the city is and it's one of those crazy
things you go to the wrong part of town
at the wrong time of day and you're not
from that town that's going to be your
perception of that town but if you go to
the right side of town on the right time
of day that's going to be your
perception of the town it's all a matter
of how you view things as all a matter
where you keep yourself how do you allow
your view to be shaped by the things
that you see and the things that you do
so again it's really kind of cool that
basically workshops living a
self-fulfilling prophecy
he believes the city's falling apart he
knows this because he spends all the
time in the parts of the city that are
falling apart so we're just confirming
his own bias you're simply saying I have
a belief system and now I'm going to
look for facts to verify that belief
system instead of taking the more
intelligent route and basically saying
here are all the facts what do these
facts conclude so again it's really kind
of a funny situation but the fact
remains here the bard
is still committing these crimes the
bard is still killing these women the
bard is still leaving their bodies for
the police to find now at this point we
actually end up joining back with the
server back at the diner now the
interesting situation with regards to
war Shack talking with Nancy the the
winters of the diner is that it's almost
like this little bit of happiness this
little bit of what could be a reasonable
situation in his life you know find a
nice girl and I wouldn't really say
settled down I have a hard time
believing that like war Shack and Nancy
would bar like a house on the
countryside pop out a couple kids settle
down and kind of live their life and you
know in a mundane fashion I have a hard
time believing that what happened like
it doesn't it wouldn't really work out
that way for his character and on the
surface we know that right I mean we
know that with these two it would never
really work out that way but the great
thing about this story and the great
thing about workshops character is we
hope it does like we hope he finds some
measure of happiness we hope he finds a
small
measure of peace but he goes somewhere
and is able to just kind of suit his
soul and chill out and just enjoy life
for what it is but it won't be that way
just because we know that this takes
place before Watchmen and we know about
his about the events during Watchmen now
of course with the survival of raw head
the first and foremost thing to focus on
is the death of war shock I mean it's
literally to kill this guy just because
of the fact that at this point it's
really just more of an insult than
anything else it's really just kind of a
pride thing now of course wrong head
uses the scenario of a couple women of
the night to basically try to lure
rorschach out which of course you
doesn't really buy into but he does kind
of follow him around now again this
secret identity that Rorschach has the
person is what allows him to walk around
in the general public and this is the
instance we were talking about of how
Rorschach could walk right behind or
right next to a head and he would never
know that it was worshipped he would
have no idea as the one he ends up doing
is basically breaking into raw heads
place and then just more or less
allowing everything to run amok I mean
literally just ripping through his guys
kind of tearing him up and calling it a
day now the funny thing is that when it
gets to the point whereby he ends up
with raw head himself that you know
workshops kind of forced to fight
against one of workshops more you know
capable guys for the entire time raw
heads just kind of dancing around acting
crazy you know doing this doing all
these little dance maneuvers and so on
and so forth and celebrating the moment
now of course this means that you know
when the mask of war Shack is pulled off
everybody knows his identity but the
insanity of rawhide begins to show
itself when he throws on the mask of war
shock and then began to kind of dance
around as Rorschach himself so again
it's pretty crazy it's pretty wild but
then we switch back to Nancy and the
reason why this matters is because of
the fact that in this citywide blackout
the words of Rorschach begin to ring
back you know when he basically tells
her hey look the city's dying this would
be successful if they're given the
opportunity if people are given the
choice between following their animal
nature and being intelligent they'll
choose their animal nature and the way
this is depicted is by looting is by
writing Nancy simply looking around at
everything that's going on and saying
when the city's at its weakest all these
people are doing is just tearing things
up they're just ripping things to pieces
they're just stealing things why because
they can't and so because of this we
actually end up finding out that the
bard has essentially targeted Nancy
that's stumbling across the two of them
the bard is also someone that Nancy
recognizes and that's kind of the
craziness of it now with regards to
worship I haven't been taken by raw head
and
I had really just kind of losing his
mind and going on about nonsense you
know and and one of his guys being left
to basically torture and kill Rorschach
in the middle of all this raw head
actually goes out into the streets of
New York to act like Rorschach now this
was kind of funny because this is a
scenario where raw head is one just kind
of getting carried away
where he's really just kind of going
absolutely bonkers but the other half
this is how he sees himself and that's
what's really kind of ironic here raw
head being a guy who has you know
basically scars and so on and so forth
all around his head basically makes the
case that when people see him they see
him for his physical appearance he can
put the mask on and he's anybody else he
can be anyone under that under that mask
and that's kind of an on running thing
when it comes to Rorschach because again
when no one knows what he looks like he
could be anybody
and so again it's really just kind of a
face in the crowd as one of the things
that were shocked always relied on
without his mask but the fact remains
that were shocked basically is able to
break free when the tiger that he had
previously used to to attack the
henchmen of Ron had basically breaks
into the room with the guy that's
torturing Rorschach and of course kills
him and then Rorschach makes his escape
and that's really the end of that but
the funny thing is that with regards to
raw head because he gets so carried away
and he takes on a bunch of these thugs
one of them breaks his neck by hitting
him in the back of the head with a
baseball bat and so he comes to an end
quick fast and in a hurry but having his
work effectively done for him
Rorschach puts his mask on and basically
calls it a night and so what ends up
happening here is we basically follow up
with him when he's tracking down the
bard and what had happened was Nancy had
survived the experience Nancy had
managed to get away and then just bailed
out on the city she literally just took
off and so we never get a resolution to
that we never find out what's going on
not only that with the Bard himself we
end up having were shot basically we
find out where the guys located at who
was a regular at the diner and kill him
and that's really it we don't get a
whole lot of exposition we don't really
get a whole lot of explanation the
reason why is designed to be that way is
because the Watchmen end of themselves
were written to be more visceral they
were written to be real tangible some of
you could look out your window and
legitimately see now I wouldn't say that
you would see a guy walking around with
a mask that's literally a constantly
rotating Rorschach inkblot test but I
will say it's not outside the realm of
possibility for a guy to put a mask on a
trench coat and a top hat and then walk
around and just start attacking people
who are committing crimes you see it all
the time vigilantism is not an uncommon
theme and so because of that it makes
sense that this is what you
without any major resolution who would
just be in the barge found and then he's
dead and that's it it makes sense that
that would be the case because that's
how you would expect it to play out in
the watchmen that's how you expected to
play out in the real world the bard may
have even gotten away with his crimes we
don't really even see what he physically
looks like all we know is that he's just
a white guy he's got dark hair we don't
see the details of his own individual
face so again this is just kind of Brian
Azzarello way bringing us a really
interesting character a really
interesting development for for war
shocker before the watchmen started i
definitely love this this information
that we got here but if you guys are new
here to come this explain make sure you
guys with the sub button to become part
of the rod core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all Leonard peace
[Music]